je suis thierry joubert jardinier au
jardin de ressent à maisonnée j'étais à
la base dans les hautes-alpes
j'étais saisonniers là-bas à faire du
maraîchage et travaillent en stations
l'hiver et je suis arrivé ici donc en
2017 ce site est avant tout un lieu
historique vu que c'était un prieuré
après maintenant petit à petit ça
devient aussi un lieu
pour les plantes donc où on
on voit
beaucoup grossi versité de plantes au
niveau des des légumes des fruits des
plantes qu'on peut utiliser qu'on peut
manger on a tout ce qui est classique
après on essaye d'avoir un peu les
légumes oubliés
il ya les pannes et rutabagas radis
noirs qui sont plus trop
qu'on trouve plus trop scorsonère
topinambours voilà et ensuite on essaye
aussi
de partir sur d'exotique on a du curcuma
du gingembre
me wade balbi voile pas mal de choses
comme ça qui sont pas connus ici mais
qui sont qui marche il faut bien dans le
nord lax pour être un bon jardinier ici
faut être déjà discret ensuite pas à
travailler trop vite quoi prendre le
temps de bien faire les choses de
prendre soin
un des plantes de ce qu'on fait pour que
tout soit
nickel on travaille pour que ce soit
joli mais aussi on travaille avant tout
pour les plantes
pour qu'elles soient en forme pour
qu'elles soient le plus belle possible
donc là on est en hiver l'hiver en
général on nous dit
que c'est le moment du repos où on n'a
pas grand chose à faire est
compte c'est le contraire en fait c'est
le moment où on a le plus de travail
donc il faut tout qu'on reprenne là à
l'otan une faute ou qu'on démonte et
ensuite on a tout ce qui est taillé
suivi aussi suivi désherbage donc
énormément de taille tout l'hiver et
ensuite au printemps on doit re préparer
le jardin
voilà pour la réouverture tout à l'heure
je pense que c'est il ya beaucoup de
monde tout l'été et l'hiver on voit
strictement personne donc il ya vraiment
pas de visite
rien donc c'est c'est très différent
c'est un peu déstabilisant aussi ce côté
là et après c'est très bien le voilà de
vivre à chaque saison parce que
était printemps été automne hiver ça n'a
rien à voir c'est dans le voit on le
voit grandir en voir s'améliorer aussi
quoi voilà ça fait plaisir ça
je suis dominée que duke viticulteur à
20 m et céréaliers sur la commune
voisine de saint symphorien
j'ai commencé à prendre ma vie
professionnelle en étant salarié dans
une coopérative agricole du cher qui
n'existent plus donc j'ai été dix ans
dans cette coopérative et puis je suis
parti en 94 et puis je me suis mis à mon
compte aussi en 95 en tant que cadre hic
mulder et puis l'activité vigna nés en
eric on a fait encore une douzaine est
bon donc cette idée est née d'un groupe
d'agriculteurs
en effet par rapport à cette époque de
la politique agricole commune qui allait
nous emmener vers les incertitudes et en
même temps de d'une émulation des gens
de devenait notre projet vigne est parti
d'une dans un esprit collectif avec
à 20 m a passé viticole intéressant
puisque dans les années 1920 il y avait
plus de 200 hectares de vignes à 20 m de
ca est née une humiliation avec cette
idée un peu saugrenue parce que c'était
compliqué sachant qu'il y avait plus de
vignes du tout leur planter de la vigne
venait donc la couleur une première
plantation élus en 97 vrai celui-là il
est bon il a fait du bois mais n'est pas
très très gros donc à mon avis il faudra
leur couper la passe qu'il a il attirait
coucher sous la baguette
il va avoir au moins dix ie10 départ
donc ça va faire beaucoup trop donc on
est quatre associés et c'est une
victoire de travailler entre quatre
agriculteurs depuis plus de 20 ans avec
quatre caractères différents avec des
aptitudes différentes
de là est née cette notre enfant qui est
ce 22ème
donc nous avons dû faire notre petit
trou puisque nous sommes une petite
niche
idéalement situé au sud de menetou-salon
sancerre halal est de castries et au
nord de châteaumeillant donc il a fallu
en effet trouvé ma que nous étions
capables de faire un produit qui tienne
la route
et puis se créer une clientèle ce qui
est ce qu a mis quelques années et bien
sûr mais duraient que la population
locale nous a bien suivi nous a bien
aidés comité des fêtes il ya deux
cartons s'il nous produisons en moyenne
entre 30 et 40 mille bouteilles ce qui
représente des rendements relativement
modeste mais qui nous suffisent pour
valoriser le terroir et avoir des va
relativement concentré avec nos six
hectares et demi on fait concurrence à
personne nous vendons notre production
principalement des particuliers 22 m
a permis donc déjà de se faire connaître
et de d'amener une valorisation à la
petite région les gens qui parlent d'eux
mêmes parle aussi souvent du vignoble et
puis ils sont fiers d'avoir leurs
produits quand il part chez leur ami de
la famille il préfère emmener une
bouteille devenait mme que s'arrêter
acheter des fleurs au coin de la rue et
je pense que ce vignoble a vocation à
prouver sa pérennité dans l'avenir et
qu'il est bien maintenant inscrit dans
le patrimoine local je suis là on les
use maréchal ferrant je suis maréchal
ferrant depuis faim depuis 33 ans
je suis la quatrième génération donc mon
père mon grand père mon
arrière-grand-père et du côté de ma mère
il était éleveur de chevaux donc ben
tout petit il ya eu des chevaux à la
maison et j'ai toujours voulu être
maréchal ferrant 16 ans je suis parti en
apprentissage j'ai été à l'école à
saumur et je travaillais chez un
maréchal ferrant à paris nous on va
juste s'occuper des pieds on verra après
très bien aller
j'ai 33 ans je fais ce métier-là rend
tout mais je suis installé dans la
région semble depuis 95
on soigne tout ce qui est possible c'est
à dire qu'on peut arriver aussi bien
pour un cheval de trait pour un anneau
un petit poney donc il faut avant tout
avoir dans son camion pour faire au
mieux aller alors les étapes on enlève
le vieux faire quand y en a un ensuite
on perd la corne en taille la corne qui
a poussé parce que là la corne pouces
d'environ 1 cm par mois on a juste le
vieux fer à la tournure du pied du
chevalet la forme de son pied le fer 9
donc il faut il faut le travailler donc
c'est pour ça qu'on chauffe
une fois qu'il a été chauffée on vérifie
voir s'il a la bonne forme
on met dans l'eau ensuite pour la tâche
avec des clous donc ça s'appelle brochet
et ensuite on coupe ses clous c'est ce
qui s'appelle river et qui met en héros
pour la fin et voilà j'ai réussi le
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
en 2011 pour pouvoir avoir ce titre faut
être courageux travailleur acharné
passionnés c'est vraiment un titre qui
vous coûte parce que c'est compliqué à
avoir votre vie de famille en prend un
coup
vous êtes vraiment quand vous êtes
dedans vous êtes dedans à fond et vous
pensé qu'à ça vous vieux pour ça vous
dormez pour ça vous lever pour ça c'est
c'est une vraie c'est une vraie ligne de
conduite après aller avec sa vue tu me
fais notre g pareil aller en avant
avoir des apprentis c'est important
parce que il faut transmettre ce métier
il faut transmettre son savoir et c'est
important qu'ils soient là qu'ils voient
comment ça se passe et qu'ils apprennent
et en regardant faisant en étant
aiguillés dans le bonnac c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive à avoir un bon résultat et
peut-être devenir bon comme c'est un
métier passion fesses et dévorant non
forcément ces épices et c'est une
multitude de choses avec une multitude
de pathologie à soigner d'animaux avoir
de nouvelles de nouvelles rencontres
donc aussi bien et kinase in et c'est
passionnant parce que on fait toujours
la même chose mais à chaque fois c'est
différent je suis allé me ferait chier
je suis agricultrice à venait j'ai une
ferme d'élevage et
sur laquelle il ya plein d'activités
parce que finalement on aime ça donc
c'est une ferme sur lequel j'ai des
vaches laitières
je fais une production de carpes koï
pour les bassins ou pour les étangs j'ai
planté quelques truffiers il ya quatre
ans j'ai des cultures pour vendre mes
céréales et j'ai des cultures aussi pour
nourrir mes vaches
donc tout ça c'est tout un panel
d'activités qui me permet d'avoir des
journées très diversifié
la dernière info la brancher en deux
fois deux voies j'ai une mammite
arrière gauche cette ferme c'est ma
ferme familiale mon père est arrivé sur
cette ferme il avait 4 ans en 51 et donc
on arrive dans notre 70e année je suis
la quatrième génération sur sur 7 sur
cette belle rebelle de belles fermes
alors au départ quand je suis revenu sur
cette ferme familiale mon idée c'était
pas de m'occuper du troupeau laitier
était de m'occuper d'un atelier qui
était en création à l'époque qui est la
pisciculture dans la pisciculture a
commencé à 93 c'est mon père qui l'avait
mise en place avec tout un atelier très
conséquent autour du poisson des temps
pour que ce qu'on appelle
réempoissonnement avec de la vente de
gardons den bossche de sang de black
bass puis demain et on videra le bassin
pour rattraper c'est une activité que
mon père a mené pendant une vingtaine
d'années jusqu'en 2012 où il a arrêté
son activité
l'atelier existants moi j'ai décidé de
continuer mais en faisant évoluer les
productions géré à orienter la
production avec des poissons tels que la
carpe koï qui est un poisson que je peux
surveiller que j'élève sur mon site
puisque je dispose d'une vingtaine de
bassins d'élevage jeu peut sécuriser
davantage la prédation des oiseaux ses
impressions que je peux vendre toute
l'année l'objectif c'est de faire de la
vente directe pour faire du circuit
court mais l'objectif de la ferme c'est
de faire aussi en sorte que nos
productions soient imbriquées les unes
dans les autres et soi interdépendantes
c'est ce qui fait de la ferme à une
image durable donc j'ai des céréales des
vaches des poissons ils ont besoin les
uns des autres et on ne va pas gaspiller
a prévu une matière
les matières produites par un atelier
sont facilement valorisé par un parent à
notre atelier et c'est ce qui fait que
tout est réfléchi pour que cela soit l'
équilibre
mon objectif n'est pas de pousser mon
système c'est de faire en sorte que
l'équilibré existe on est dans de
l'agriculture qui a du sens quoi je suis
bouillonnante d'idées j'ai encore une
bonne dizaine d'années à faire
j'aimerais bien voir des jeunes revenir
dans la cour mais irene
j'ai plein dans vie mais après à chacun
ses projets moi je veux bien des gens à
développer des projets mais j'ai pas
forcément envie de les porter
intégralement tout seul
[Musique]